[Musique]
m
non
le
[Musique]
on va embrayer sur l'actualité chypriote
olivier delamarche qu'est ce que vous
pouvez nous dire sur la situation de
chypre l'étonnant les à côtés sans les
mécanismes a joué par
roger ou pas on nous a dit que c'était
fini que c'était réglé moi j'ai
l'impression que ça n'est pas du tout on
va en reparler dans peu de temps on a
bien vu quand même que ça a été géré la
façon la plus stupide qui soit
on a fermé les banques chypriotes à
chypre mais on a oublié de les fermer à
londres et résultat vous avez une bonne
partie des fonds qui ont été exfiltrés
des banques donc
résultat on va s'apercevoir dans
quelques jours ou quelques semaines que
les 6 milliards qu'on devait récupérer
sont pas là et à ce moment là il faudra
tout recommencer donc comme d'habitude
comme qui a été fait en grèce comme ce
qui a été fait à chaque fois ça a été
fait en dépit du bon sens et donc
on fait les choses mal comme d'habitude
et donc ça aboutit à ce que le problème
soit pas du tout régler et que on en
reparle semaine après semaine pendant
des mois et des mois et des mois et des
mois et que donc on va arriver dans
quelques donc quelques temps un à un un
problème qui sera qui sera comme celui
de la grèce avec malheureusement des
signaux qui ont été données qui vont
déclencher pour moi
je pense un bank run dans les pays
faibles
dont la france un neveu ne nous excluons
pas de ces pays là g admettons qu'un
pays sorte de l'union européenne
le pays qui a aisni les 06 et euro se
retrouvent dans d'autres banques
centrales parce que ces euro deviendront
des actifs toxiques
bah oui évidemment ça va poser une grave
une grave difficulté parce que
actuellement aucun processus de sortie
d'un pays de la zone euro n'existe on
voit même que dans les textes les canons
sa sert a sans doute pour sortir l'euro
faut sortir de l'union européenne on
voit qu'on est quand même très loin
d'avoir une gestion souple à ce niveau
là et j'y prends pas tout à fait exclue
que ce soit un des premiers pays sur
lequel on tentera une expérimentation de
sortie de la zone euro ayant même
l'association internationale des
banquiers pousse un peu dans cette seule
dans cette voie là la difficulté
évidemment et que sur la situation à
chypre un
moment d'occidental a fait trois quatre
fois plus des dettes que ce qui ne
pourra probablement jamais remboursé
depuis 2008 on a un début de retour à la
réalité mais on est toujours dans une
situation où les prêteurs pense
évidemment qu'ils seront remboursés et
les emprunteurs pense que de toute façon
ils ne pourront jamais rembourser ou en
tout cas qu'ils n'auront pas de
nom pas faire face et de lever massives
d'impôts à court terme impôts qui est de
toute façon si on les levait serait
extrêmement destructeur pour voir
l'économie
chypre est le premier pays sur lesquels
on a un début de retour à la réalité qui
est que toutes ses pertes
eric actuellement son comptable vols
sont en train d'être redescendu vers les
arts les personnes physiques donc
évidemment chypre n'a pas eu cette fois
deux plans dead pour ne pas impacter sa
population comme a eu la grèce ou comme
ont eu d'autres pays ces plans ayant
toujours été financée par de la dette
supplémentaire donc à chypre en asie on
ne veut plus faire de dette et donc
comme on veut plus faire de dettes le
système est en faillite et donc voilà
chacun intervenant va prendre ses pertes
évidemment les actionnaires des banques
en premier lieu puis les prêteurs
obligataires des banques y en a pas
beaucoup à chypre évidemment les très
gros déposants puis ce n'est pas garanti
au delà de cent mille euros
donc oui à chypre et en est un
un petit laboratoire alors effectivement
extrêmement déplaisant pour la
population et non c'est catastrophique
ce qui se passe à chypre en train de
ruminer la plupart des entreprises parce
qu'évidemment leur trésorerie est amputé
la même façon plus les on va dire au
moins les déposants moyen à très gros de
lille malheureusement c'est que peut-on
faire d'autre dans cette situation
bernard oui juste juste un mot c'est un
tout petit problème c'est un problème et
si le skc pinacci prince et 0,05 pour
cent de la richesse européenne du pnd
européen simplement ça pose après nos
principes en cas de sortie qui est celui
de l'extension lalanne en tache d'huile
ceux des deux des conséquences de cette
sortie vis-à-vis d'autres états alors eu
beaucoup plus significatif en terme de
parts dans la richesse européenne mais
surtout surtout l'histoire de chypre
démontre une fois de plus on a construit
l'euro en allant vers si vous dira à
l'encontre du bon sens on a mis ensemble
un certain nombre de pays complètement
hétérogène sur le plan économique qui
n'avait pas atteint le stade le même
stade de maturité et on a créé une
monnaie unique entre une monnaie unique
entre eux le résultat c'est
qu'effectivement un certain nombre de
pays ne sont pas capables de respecter
la discipline qui résulte de cette
monnaie ait surtout quand elle a été
levée vers le haut par la la la position
de l'allemagne en fait ce qu'il aurait
fallu faire c'est évident maintenant
mais certains l'ont dit écrire avant
c'est attendre qu'ils aient un minimum
de cohérence économique entre les
nations puis là comment faire entrer
dans l'euro des nations ayant le même
statut économique la même cohérence
économique la même richesse économique
est ce que vous pensez est-ce que vous
pensez que l'allemagne a poussé deux
pour faire entrer des pays faibles pour
que l'euro est une valeur moins forte
facile quand ses exportations je ne
pense pas je pense que l'allemagne
a toujours soutenu une politique de
monnaie forte à l'époque du deutsche
mark et maintenant à l'époque de l'euro
l'euro étant en quelque sorte pour les
allemands le succédané de douche marque
pour que les allemands se satisfont
parfaitement d'une madness si tu vois un
niveau élevé par rapport aux autres
grandes monnaies internationales
donc ils ne cherchent pas du tout à la
baisse-- par ce genre de phénomène en
fait ils ont été pris dans un espèce de
de pièges que j'appelle infernale pour
ma part par lequel le sens d'ailleurs
que les peuples européens le sache ne le
sache les le sens de même on a créé en
étant très dense est mené avec dédé des
composantes des composants des états
qu'ils n'avaient aucune homogénéité
économique donc tout ça ne pouvait pas
tenir tout ça venait à éclater un jour
votre lecture de ceux qui auraient la
capacité d'agir c'est à dire le brussels
les dirigeants les principaux dirigeants
européens est ce que leur capacité
d'action vous semble réaliste face à
l'ampleur du problème la seule façon de
permettre aux états marginaux si j'ose
dire économiquement dans l'euro la seule
façon de leur permettent de tenir dans
l'euro ce serait d'abaisser la valeur de
l'euro contre les autres comme dans les
autres me faire une dévaluation a dit
boudreau conquis et de rapport au dollar
par exemple de 1 20 à 25 que tous les
économistes ont en tête et qui respecte
d'ailleurs ça tombe de ratios
économiques mais et financier mais
comment t'est arrivé je ne crois pas que
ce soit l'action des états qu'il
permettra au ca et la loi c'est la loi
de l'offre et de la demande qui régule
tous les jours la parité des monnaies et
encore une fois ce l'euro et dans une
large mesure influencé par la santé
éclatante encore aujourd'hui de
l'allemagne olivier avec les attentes en
terme de 2 comment dire de croissance ou
libériez il à l'allemagne est elle si on
forme que ça non non c'est sûr que
l'allemagne allait pas oui par rapport
aux autres aujourd'hui elle et elle va
elle va mieux
la question c'est évidemment quand la
récession va gagner les autres pays aux
alentours qui sont ses principaux
clients évidemment qu'elle ira l'ira mal
son modèle est extrêmement
déséquilibrée en fait extrêmement
tourner vers les verts les exportations
moi j'aurais aimé réagir sur la partie
et sur la partie rollin videmment je
partage tout à fait la vision notamment
qui est une aberration d'aller faire
entrer des pays tels que évidemment
chypre enfin même l'adresse dans une
dans une zone monétaire comme comme les
l'europe ait assez peu discussion là
dessus et là où il peut y en avoir une
c'est même est ce qu'on peut faire une
monnaie unique est rentrer entre entre
les pays en tout cas pour que ça marche
quelles sont les conditions et est ce
que ces conditions sont existants en
europe moi je pense qu'il est impossible
impossible un horizon de cinq ans temps
d'aller faire une monnaie unique entre
la france et l'allemagne par exemple
pourquoi parce qu'évidemment quand vous
faites une monnaie unique vous vous
privez de larmes de la faim forcément
d'évaluation en tout cas dépréciations
pour tenter de rééquilibrer des
économies divergentes si vous faites une
monnaie unique il va falloir en cas
d'écarts de compétitivité
rééquilibrer les choses et s'il ya plus
de possibilités faire quelque chose au
niveau des monnaies il faut les faire au
niveau où des salaires de la
compétitivité des pays en tout cas il
faut que 1 d'une part on est des pays
qui soit capable plus ou moins de se
réformer et deuxièmement d'avoir des
pays qui ait une vision non plus de
guerre économique mais de paix
économique tout comme aujourd'hui
l'alsace à n'essaye pas de baisser ses
salaires par rapport
midi pyrénées ça ne peut pas marcher
contrainte dans cette situation là donc
il faut qu'ils aient une vraie vision de
coopération aujourd'hui fin 15 ans
d'expérience de l'euro montre qu'on est
au contraire dans des phases de plus en
plus divergentes où chaque pays fait ce
qu'il veut sans demander l'avis aux
autres quand l'allemagne baisse des
salaires en 2002-2003 demande pas les
vieux autres qu'en irlande baisse son
taux d'impôt sur les sociétés des
banques pas aux autres quoi la france
fait les 35 heures elle ne demande pas
aux autres bien ou mal peu importe en
tout cas chaque pays a fait ce qu'il a
voulu son se dire que de toute façon on
est en train de partager un espace
commun qui est qui et la monnaie
monsieur de la marche qu'est ce que vous
pouvez me dire sur l'irlande sur le
fiscalité irlandaise l'irlande c'est une
aberration c'est à dire que l'irlande
c'était un pays sur lequel il y avait
trois moutons et de distilleries de
whisky d'accord pipe aux pays pauvres et
on le faire entrer dans l'euro alors je
suis tout à fait d'accord avec avec
olivier on fait entrer dans l'euro
on les autorise ou non les pouces où on
leur suggère je ne sais pas exactement
comment ça s'est passé mais de deux de
faire une zone quasi franche avec un
impôt à 12% donc en fait on se sont
introduits dans l'euro un paradis fiscal
1 c'est ni plus ni moins ça on n'en
parle pas beaucoup comme un paradis
fiscal aujourd'hui on s'occupe plutôt de
la suisse mais c'en est un et
et de fait ça ne peut pas marcher c'est
à dire qu'on s'y noculak engrais mais on
attend que ça se passe et après quand
évidemment ça a créé une bulle une bulle
immobilière une bulle
en irlande et que cette bulle a explosé
et qu'il a fallu aller sauver les
banques les irlandais ont dit ah ouais
mais sion si on casse le modèle de
d'impôt à 12% on est finie alors tout de
suite l'europe à dia bomba donc on garde
son garde ce modèle c'est ridicule ça ne
peut pas fonctionner ça ne peut pas
fonctionner et ça on l'a esquisse qui
est étonnante ou même vous avez parlé du
montage de l'euro mais c'est bien plus
tard on a fait rentrer chez eux en 2008
dans l'euro c'est donc on sait que ça
marche pas on sait qu'il ya un problème
mais on continue bernard encore n'aurait
fait rentrer chypre
chaque personne ne le sait c'est ça le
drame c'est qu'aucun européen aucun des
400 millions d'européens de c'est pour
qu'on a fait un très chic et d'ailleurs
aucun des 400 millions européen a suivi
de près le processus d'élaboration de
l'euro et le fait qu' on a mis la
charrue avant les boeufs c'est à dire
qu'il aurait fallu attendre une
convergence accrue encore une fois entre
les économies des états souhaitant
entrer dans cette monnaie unique avant
de la cré nous savons que les états unis
ont poussé l'union européenne à
s'élargir on l'a vu par rapport à la
turquie les tractations sur la turquie
est-ce que vous pensez que les états
unis ont poussé l'europe à s'élargir
soit pour l'affaiblir économiquement
pour reprendre le leadership ou soit
c'était de l'altruisme pure et simple au
départ les américains et surtout
kissinger d'ailleurs quand il était
secrétaire d'état auprès de nixon
notamment repoussé effectivement à la
création de l'europe pour une raison
tout à fait simple et d'ailleurs je
crois qu'il faut respecter il souhaitait
que par ce biais on met fin
définitivement aux tensions qui a eu
lieu au conflit qui a eu lieu et qui
avait été sanguinaire en prêt les pays
européens dans le passé voilà ils
souhaitaient les éviter la répétition
des des conflits de la qui ont conduit à
la seconde guerre mondiale et aussi à la
première d'ailleurs et a ensuite est-ce
que l'extension ils ont poussé
massivement oui alors pour des raisons
que j'ignore à dire vrai ce que c'était
pour affaiblir l'europe
je crois qu'il faut pas toujours accuser
les états de machiavélisme l'état hélas
d'ailleurs parfois sur bouaké moins
machiavélique on imagine olivier le raja
soit pourquoi pourquoi chypre moi je
pense simplement qu'on l'a fait rentrer
par inconscience donc comme on a fait
l'euro par inconscience quand on creuse
un peu pourquoi on a fait l'euro on a
fait l'euro comme un symbole politique
d'intégration européenne semences un
joli symbole d'intégration politique ses
pratiques d'avoir une seule monnaie dans
la zone la difficulté que c'est que ça a
des conséquences au bout de 10 à 15 ans
qui sont extrêmement lourdes sur sur les
économies d'ailleurs on les laisserait
faire mais non c'est très simple
aujourd'hui d'aller fans monnaie unique
entre l'europe et la chine
1 on se met d'accord avec les dirigeants
chinois de ont créé une banque centrale
3 elle aimait d euros yann dans la zone
c'est pas compliqué par contre au bout
de dix ans vous allez vous apercevoir
que vaille à 25 % de chômage en europe
est que ça va mieux en chine mais c'est
à dire il faut beaucoup de temps pour
voir les conséquences négatives d'une
décision très sympathique politique on
continue d'ailleurs enfin la lettonie
avec 10 retraits au 1er janvier ou le 14
ça va faire en continu et c'est à dire
que on a un problème on sait que l'euro
est quand même très très malade
aujourd'hui même si après on peut
toujours dire ce qui va éclater ce qui
va pas éclater peu importe on a une
monnaie qui est malade on a un système
qui est malade on a un système dans
lequel on s'endette de plus en plus pour
essayer de venir au secours de un tel ou
d'un tel est aujourd'hui tout ce qu'on
trouve à faire c'est continuer à faire
rentrer des pays c'est en dépit de tout
bon sens faire rentrer des pays dans le
dans le la zone euro on va me dire oui
on s'y était engagé peu importe on a un
problème aujourd'hui au lieu d'essayer
de le régler on est en train d'essayer
de l'aggraver donc je retiens surtout
que ce qu'est ce qu'il ya c'est fou
c'est par exemple on ne m'a même pas
comme règle pour entrer dans la zone
euro d'avoir par exemple un salaire
moyen au moins égale à la moyenne de la
zone euro ou un taux d'impôt sur les
sociétés au moins égale à la moyenne
pour arrêter de tirer vers le bas et
d'augmenter les divergences de la zone
dernier point sur la lettonie qu'on
appelle déjà la future chypre quand même
parce que c'est évidemment un pays à
très basses fiscalité pesant qui est
vrai que 9% des lettons qui sont pour
entrer dans la zone euro mais enfin
c'est quand même fantastique derrière la
lettonie quatre ou cinq étages sont en
train de café non mais quel effet
on voit tout un tas plusieurs états de
l'europe de l'uciac la pologne mais je
crois qui fait preuve de sagesse oui
exactement je reviens encore sur
chevreuil et le fonds de garantie des
dépôts bancaires est-ce que c'est
correctement provisionnés est ce que il
ya eu des exercices pour pouvoir le
mettre en place rapidement des
simulations pour mettre en place est-ce
que vous pensez que les pouvoirs publics
au moins un français sont en mesure de
garantir aux français qu'eux si un état
ou si leur ont fait défaut ou si leur
banque fait défaut est-ce que leur
épargne en euros sera garantie à hauteur
de 100 millions
pour le fonds de garantie est quand même
pas bien pas bien gros il n'a que des
milliards actuellement d'euros qu'est ce
que ça veut dire pas bien gros
by admin milliards à peu près de dépôts
est le fonds fait 2 milliards ceci étant
vous avez malgré tout un amortisseur qui
concerne les dépôts non garantis en ci
représente à peu près 500 milliards sur
l'ensemble donc autrement dit en cas pas
à 500 milliards de pertes a que deux des
gros déposants ont pas quitté le système
bancaire vous pouvez amortir tout de
même beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de chocs
ce qui est plus gênant d'ailleurs sur le
fonds de garantie des dépôts on a très
peu parlé dans la loi bancaire actuel il
est en train d'être fusionnée avec un
fonds de garantie enfin un fonds de
résolution qui doit venir en aide aux
banques en difficulté
autrement dit on est en train de
mélanger les fonds qui étaient censés
être destiné uniquement à la
préservation de l'épargné des déposants
vers un fonds qui pourra servir à
recapitaliser demain crédit agricole ou
société générale alors qu'ils ont été
beaucoup plus sain de faire deux fonds
différents comme l'europe le permettait
en parlant des fonds monsieur de la
marche qu'est ce que vous pensez des
fonds propres de la banque centrale
européenne
les fonds propres de la banque centrale
européenne je sais pas c'est pas c'est
pas un problème puisque
puisque rien n'a rien n'empêche on l'a
vu quand même de nombreux soit rien
n'empêche de faire marcher la planche à
billets donc à partir de ce moment là le
bilan des banques centrales et le le le
les fonds propres des banques centrales
n'ont pas un
intérêt fou là c'est la seule chose
qu'on peut dire c'est qu'aujourd'hui
vous avez vous avez vu ce qui s'est
passé au moment de du soi-disant
règlement
ce2 de la grèce le haircut qui c'est qui
s'est passé pourquoi est ce qu'on a fait
un air code qui était en en fait tout à
fait limité est limité je vous rappelle
aux obliques qui était de droit grec et
non pas aux obliques de droit
international qui obligent les hobbies
des obligations de de droit grec c'est à
dire émis en droit greg donc en gros
détenu uniquement par les banques
grecques tout ce qui était
émis en droit international n'était pas
concertés concernés par le hair cut mais
c'est surtout que la bce a dit oui je
veux bien pour le secteur privé mais pas
pour moi parce que entre ce qu'ils
avaient en direct dans les obligations
souveraines grecques plus les
collatéraux qu'ils avaient accepté il
avait il en allait pour 200 milliards
bon alors de 100 milliards 75% ça fait
150 les fonds propres de la bce de
mémoires doivent être autour de 13
milliards il me semble se confirmer
13 milliards 13 milliards - 150 ça fait
quand même un gros trou et ça fait
désordre
donc voila mais aujourd'hui
sinon
on parle de ça aussi sur le sur le bilan
de la fed peu importe le bilan de la fed
il peut il pourrait à la limite
quasiment doublé il suffit d'imprimer ce
qu'il faut monsieur bernanke n'est pas
un grand spécialiste de ça ils nous ont
fait 4 milliards tous les jours
s'il ya besoin il en fera 8 me suis
engagé je vous vois sourire non non je
suis
effectivement heureusement d'ailleurs
qui fait tourner il est d'une certaine
façon la planche à billets américaine
parce qu'il introduit des liquidités
dans le dispositif et ça permet de
maintenir des taux d'intérêt faibles
enfin tout ça dans la loterie siens dans
la crise mais pas dans l'économie
maladroite en économie berroyer les
fonds les fonds émis par la banque
centrale américaine la fed n'arrive
toujours pas sur l'économie réelle
pourquoi un pape à ce que vaut
aujourd'hui reste dans la partie
d'économie financière enfin ça y arrive
parce que c'est un des six directement
mais c'est vrai que ça sert à alimenter
des fut
déçu spéculatifs pour la plupart et
c'est pas pour rien qu'il est tout de
même la bourse américaine et retrouve
ses niveaux d'avant la crise a faim
c'est quand même si réaliste
vous pensez vraiment que ces fonds sont
là pour maintenir les différents indices
boursiers hassan hadad mais il est en
berne on te l'a dit il l'a dit
officiellement il a dit
ça ne sert qu'à une chose c'est à faire
monter lundi ce donc c'est bien pas il
n'ya pas il n'y a pas d'autres raisons
je sais pas si vous vous souvenez vous
en 2011 quand même la banque
d'angleterre a demandé un rapport à un
certain nombre d'experts en demandant ce
qu'ils quelles étaient les conséquences
qu'elle était là qu'elle était la partie
de son quantitative easing qui était
revenu dans l'économie pas si vous vous
souvenez de ce qui s'est passé au bout
d'un moment les experts reviennent
auprès de la banque d'angleterre donnent
leur rapport en disant il ya à peine 3 %
du quantitative easing qui est rentré
dans l'économie réelle
conclusion de la bo bas on en refait un
deuxième ça a si bien marché et encore
heureux que ça ne revienne pas dans
l'économie puisque vu les masses qui
sont injectés sa part ferait pleurer ma
niveau d'inflation tout de même non
négligeable acquis dans le système
actuel de taux bas de bulle obligataire
majeur serait catastrophique pour
voilà pour les comptes des banques et
des détenteurs de ses affidés simon un
petit mot sur la politique de
quantitative easing du japon qu'est ce
que vous en pensez monsieur exemplaire
de la politique la politique de
quantitative easing c'est suivre suivre
la politique pour imprimer ou faire
dévaluer sa monnaie bon là je n'avais
pas d'idée show le japonais tellement en
cours sur le japon il vient de se
suicider quoi pourquoi il suscite de
plus en plus j'ai bu j'ai vu un
déclaration de de
monsieur ab ce week-end ou d'immuniser
finances peu importe
qui annonce est une espèce de surenchère
on dirait deux adolescents dans la cour
d'école un train de mesures est celui
qui va le plus loin sika health
interview connaît l'ancien ministre des
finances japonais si vous devriez si
vous deviez lui poser une question
quelles questions vous lui poserez
abeilles se jugent jusqu'où ils vont
aller dans le sud c'est à dire là ils
ont l'air d'accélérer quand même pas mal
les choses je vous dis sont en train de
2,2 d'être en compet avec monsieur
bernanke c'est à celui qui rachète fera
le plus d'obligations
mène là ils ont annoncé des chiffres qui
sont totalement ahurissant donc
vous allez avoir je pense que le tout le
monde de blood aujourd'hui pour parce
que le yen était passé de 81 13 sur
cette bonne nouvelle à 98 je pense qu'on
n'a pas fini de le voir baisser et que
c'est vraiment pour le coup c'est
vraiment une monnaie de singe c'est à
dire que il faut qu il faut qu faudrait
quand même que les banquiers centraux
arrête de penser que en jouant au
monopoly on arrive à redresser une
économie là il son lit sont en plein jeu
valoir en pleine fuite en avant en
pleine cavalerie et ça va se terminer
très mal monsieur monsieur
annoncé c'est un phénomène tout à fait
mystérieux je veux dire créé au début de
la pause qu'on appelait au départ la
pose du japon j'ai joué je sentais qu'il
s'agit certainement comme je ne pense
pas que ce soit mystérieux pour singer
view c'est une dévaluation compétitive
entre entre je vais prendre trois grands
blocs le japon l'europe et les états
unis et je vous ferai rebondir dessus
sur le sujet guerre économique monsieur
bérurier message à dire en effet la
bouche c'était un acte de guerre
économique par par d'évaluation mais ça
va beaucoup plus loin que ça puisque
c'est vraiment vouloir déclencher de de
l'inflation un niveau et c'est carabine
et vu les niveaux qui sont qui sont
imprimés et je reviens sur ce que je
disais tout à l'heure quand vous avez
deux à trois fois plus de dette que ce
que vous pourrez jamais rembourser votre
situation qui est assez désespérée donc
vous continuez votre cavalerie tant que
ça marche et vous en sortez comment soit
vous tentez vraiment de lever ces
sommes-là sous forme d'impôts et la
partie déclenché la récession carabine
et qui de toute façon vont augmenter
elle même et déficits soit vous faites
un défaut francs à la grecque en disant
ah non excusez moi vraiment je peux pas
remboursé renégocions et puis voyons la
perte que que vous allez prendre soit
vous tentez effectivement de jouer avec
votre banque centrale pour rembourser en
monnaie de singe en utilisant la planche
à billets mais ce qui est une forme
d'aidé faut également qu'il est
l'inflation pour hambourg ce oui
évidemment
c'est je pense à ce qui va se passer en
premier lieu là où ce sera possible
demandez pas trop en europe mais aux
états-unis au japon c'est assez logique
qui se passe ça parce que pourquoi ces
c'est plus facile entre guillemets même
si c'est plus d'instructeurs pour
l'économie est sans doute le plus
injuste
géré par lâcheté politique vaut mieux
commencer par ça c'est une lâcheté
politique évidemment une lâcheté
politique est un art ne pas oser allait
renégocier sa dette et le dire mais je
vous rembourser en imprimant des sommes
colossales et samedi derrière ya un vrai
problème changé donc je ne venais pas la
solution pour me paquet que ce pays a
connu une chevauchée absolument effrénée
sur pour l'économie qu'un partant de
très bas arrivera un jour le niveau de
vie occidental dans dr raucourt et
détente croissance annuelle de l'ordre
de 7 à 10% et puis tout à coup tout
s'est arrêté et ça fait bien quinze ans
que cet arrêt durant des bleus ont fait
se dire c'est le repos du guerrier d'une
certaine façon des japonais une pause
dans la croissance et pas du tout c'est
un arrêt complet qui ne l'ont ils
n'arrivent pas à sortir et ils ont
expérimenté je ne sais combien de
premier ministre de politique économique
et inand semble toujours pas comme si
d'une certaine façon les japonais
étaient faits pour gravir des montagnes
très pentu très raide mais pas du tout
pour gérer un plateau est ce que vous ne
pensez pas qu'on est face à deux à deux
phénomènes et le japon et quelque part
un peu en avance sur nous montre la voie
qui est que 1 d'une part un bas
l'économie allait développer la haye et
c'est beau il ya à peu près tout ce
qu'il faut en moyenne en moyenne pour la
population c'est difficile d'aller me
faire croître une économie qui a déjà
crû et deuxièmement c'est une économie
c'est une population vieillissante elle
est en train de diminuer la population
du japon donc outre la dives la baisse
du nombre de personnes et surtout le
vieillissement donc c'était économie
beaucoup moins dynamique que par le
passé et donc arriver une forme de
plateaux de croissance c'est
relativement logique et je pense que
c'est ce qui est devant nous la question
est pourquoi ne réfléchissons pas sûr
qu'est ce qu'on fait quand je suis dans
un régime de croissance nulle on voit
qu'aujourd'hui il ya un refus
quasi intégristes les avez-vous pensé à
que ce n'est pas un refus mais plutôt
un groupe ayant été formé avec un style
de pensée et comme ceux ci de penser ils
vont continuer à faire du moins à
essayer de faire perdurer ce système de
pensée ils n'ont pas appris à penser en
dehors de la boîte ça mais c'est ce que
j'appelle un déni de réalité
enfin moi j'ai 37 ans la croissance elle
est parti acheter des clopes avant que
je naisse quoi elle est parvenue et on
continue à dire l'année prochaine et
sera là il va falloir qu'on dit elle
nous reviendra plus et qu'on adopte
l'économie est dramatique c'est con non
seulement évidemment on ne fait rien
mais on n'en est même pas là bien on
refuse de le penser il a pratiquement
pas un économiste en france qui
réfléchis qu'est ce que je fais en
croissance nulle vous ne trouvez pas une
thèse vous trouvez pas des financements
pour réfléchir sur sa manie ni un
économiste et un politique regardez les
déclarations de ministre des finances
monsieur moscovici qui lui dit
oui alors veut pas dire autrement donc
qui dit on aura zéro croissance en 2013
et met 1 3 en 2014 2 en 2015 ça y est on
est reparti comme en 14 donc ça sera ça
vous verrez que début 2014 il dira ah
bah oui je dois convenir que nous sommes
toujours à zéro voire en négatif et
mais vous inquiétez pas en 2015 on
reprend et en 2016 on aura 3 % de
croissance c'est toujours la même chose
ça fait vingt ans que ça dure comme
comme le dit olivier donc parce qu'on
s'est pas aperçu que en fait alors
qu'ils années s'est pas inversé la
courbe de 2 2 qui a été construite par
je sais plus quel économiste américain
qui dit qu depuis 1950 on perd un
pourcent de conscience tous les dix ans
on perd 1% de croissance tous les dix
ans donc il va falloir s'y faire
aujourd'hui on est plus dans une dans un
système où on avait de la croissance par
la démographie là c'est fini dans
beaucoup de pays c'est pas fini qu'au
japon c'est finir en allemagne c'est
fini aux états unis s'est finie en chine
avec leur politique de l'enfant unique
c'est fini dans dans une grande partie
du monde et vous avez en plus
d'aider tout ce qui est
industrialisation moteur à explosion
électricité etc qui ne qui ne se
reproduise pas aujourd'hui donc
aujourd'hui c'est pas parce que votre
ipad va aller deux fois plus vite que ça
va changer le monde donc et que ça va
vous apporter de la croissance et la
productivité donc la seule productivité
qu'on connaisse aujourd'hui c'est de
virer les gens et ça ça va en général il
ya un petit retour sur le sur la topline
sur le sur le chiffre d'affaires qui se
fait assez rapidement jeu je voudrais
votre regard dont il ya une formule
qu'on pourrait impliquer au japon par
nou ké d'einstein qui s'applique à l'
aquila appliquer lui-même à la physique
fondamentale et qui est la suivante
pensez à côté eh bien je me demande si
cette formule ne mériterait pas d'être
appliqué à l'économie à l'économie du
japon en particulier rebondir elle est
très belle phrase aussi qui a dit qu'on
ne résout pas les problèmes avec les
mêmes modes de pensée qui les ont créés
c'est exactement ça c'est une pensée
commune aussi à jacques blanc
je vais vous poser une question sur les
principaux acteurs macroéconomique
l'indicateur indicateurs ont-ils été
dévoyé où c'est une carence des
journalistes et politiques dans leurs
interprétations est-ce que vous pensez
que ces indicateurs sont encore opérant
pour une lecture correcte qu'est ce que
vous pouvez me dire là dessus
ufr n'a quasiment pas parlé des
indicateurs et n'a pratiquement qu'un
qui s'appelle croissance croissance
croissance croissance interne et
croissance en parle d'augmentation du
produit intérieur brut pas inintéressant
mais le problème c'est que un c'est
extrêmement un parfait ce seul
indicateur là c'est en gros l'équivalent
d'un chiffre d'affaires pour les
entreprises imaginer que l'on analyse
les entreprises juste en regardant leur
chiffre d'affaires et que disait
vivement que le chiffre d'affaires monté
vous regardez jamais si le résultat est
positif ou négatif mais et si le
résultat est négatif sont opaques entre
chiffre d'affaires et on en est là géré
produit intérieur brut vous ne
comptabiliser dedans jamais le fait que
vous tapez dans des ressources
naturelles qui s'épuise à type le
pétrole et vous ne comptabiliser pas la
pollution que vous générez qu'il ya vous
parler du pétrole est ce que me
connaissait le pic de l'ubs et rapide de
production pétrolière et est-ce que vous
pensez que les dettes émises ces
pyramides de ponzi
celle étatiques sont une façon de fuir
la réalité géologique de l'énergie
oui alors alpiq délibère à 17 67 yens
c'est une fonction mathématique qui dit
qu'à partir du moment où vous avez un
stock de quelque chose fini et que vous
taper dedans quand vous avoir à la
production qui va monter puis un jour
enfin ça va monter ça va arriver à zéro
quand vous aurez fini donc ça passe par
un maximum
et puis et puis ça redescend et hubert a
montré que sur des champs de pétrole en
fait ça fait une jolie courbe un peu un
peu en cloche relativement symétrique
jusqu'à présent non n'est pas arrivé au
pic mondial qui pourrait changer changer
des choses n'en a pas forcément un pic
en aura sans doute un plateau qui va
durer et sans doute une dizaine d'années
c'est une pique qui se déplace oui enfin
olympique qui se déplace un petit peu
mais enfin on voit de toute façon votre
plateau il va durer à peu près entre
2010 et 2020 voilà à peu près ce qu'on
ce monsieur je me suis en d1 vous étiez
proche des pouvoirs
à l'arrivée du premier choc pétrolier
comment se sont comportés les
institutions françaises pour gérer c'est
ce phénomène nouveau
le premier choc pétrolier ait lieu à
l'automne 1973 il s'est traduit été très
brutal il s'est traduit dans la commune
publiée aujourd'hui par une décroissance
de la du pnb mondial en fin de la
plupart des grands pays développés en 74
on a chuté de 2% des reconnu ce qu'on
avait connu ce qu'on a connu récemment
je dirais puis la croissance a repris
ce qu'on a connu ce qu'on est très très
faible comment ce qu'on a comme ceux
qu'on a connus ou ce que nous sommes en
somme nous sommes en train de connaître
vos derrière il ya un certain
parallélisme en ce qui concerne la la
chute du pnb entre la première crise
pétrolière d'ailleurs aussi la seconde
celle de 2 119 80 hélas la situation
actuelle les couve n'ont rien à voir
mais en tant de situations là économique
s'en sont extrêmement différents
comment a t'on gérer ça m'a d'abord on a
géré par anticipation c'est à dire que
d'une certaine façon en france
on l'a vu venir on l'avait vu venir
puisqu'on a
essayer de se prémunir contre cette
hausse du prix du pétrole en lançant un
programme nucléaire
à grande échelle est tout à fait
invraisemblable s'ils voulaient si vous
voulez quand vous le regardez avec le le
comment dire le regarde aujourd'hui les
une aide aujourd'hui on a en quelques
années construit lancé 30 centrales
nucléaires ont fait quelque chose
d'extravagant quelque chose qu'on ne
fera plus jamais ce que ça a été
réfléchi avant de lancer ses trente
centres alors oui tout à fait ça a été
mûrement réfléchi à l'occasion plusieurs
conseillers restera à l'elysée qui a
présidé le le chef de l'état georges
pompidou en l'occurrence que j'ai à vous
préparer d'ailleurs et dont j'ai rédigé
des relevés décision qui avait été
corrigé par le le chef de l'état tous
ces relevés des sous c'est conseil
restreint entre lyon 69 ont prévu
l'hypothèse un jour d'une hausse du prix
du pétrole et la dépendance excessive
que nous avions par rapport à ce pétrole
dans notre approvisionnement énergétique
et c'est ce qui a conduit à ce lancement
d'un plan duclair massif sur laquelle
nous vivons encore aujourd'hui dans dans
une large mesure comment se sont
comportés les autres pays est ce que
vous avez eu une perception des services
de renseignement par exemple allemand ou
espagnol est ce que ces services de
renseignement se sont intéressés à vos
travaux ou est ce que vous étiez seul
contre nous il s'agissait pas
spécialement des services d enseignement
nos travaux étaient public a rendez
compte de chaque conseil restreint au
journaliste accrédité à l'elysée dès la
fin de ce conseil restreint il suffisait
d'observer nos décisions et nos
décisions étaient d'une grande clarté
effectivement elles ont été imités dans
plusieurs pays mais les américaines
n'avaient pas attendu appel est
également lancé un programme nucléaire
avant nous d'accord mais pas de la même
ampleur sur le bâtiment alors pays sur
le pétrole monsieur de la marche 1 je
vais vous poser une question je vais
essayer très simple
toutes ces dettes émises à nos yeux ne
sont basées sur aucune réalité
énergétique calorifique c'est à dire 1
dollar 1 euro vaut autant de calories
nous synthétisons le pouvoir d'achat par
le nombre de calories acheter ou
assimilables est-ce que vous pensez que
les banques centrales sont conscientes
que les monnaies et nice ne sont basées
sur aucune réalité énergétique
enfin
près savoir de quoi est conscient
monsieur bernanke ou autre c'est
compliqué
mais
quelle qu'elle soit consciente que de
toute façon le la monnaie qu'elle émette
mais basé sur rien je pense que oui
le savent aujourd'hui c'est exactement
comme si pour expliquer aux gens un peu
ce que c'est parce que le on parle
beaucoup de quantitative easing
démission de planche à billets etc
général et les gens comprennent pas
grand chose à ce que à ce qu'on raconte
mais
c'est exactement aujourd'hui comme si
vous aviez quelqu'un qui aimait t 4
milliards par jour de chèques en bois
c'est à dire basé sur rien si vous êtes
sûr que le type qui vous fait un chèque
en face de vous à la provision sur son
compte ça vaut quelque chose vous pouvez
aller échanger votre chèque contre
contre quelque chose contre une voiture
contre n'importe quoi à partir du moment
où
les peuples vont penser qu' il n'y a
rien sur le compte son son sa monnaie la
monnaie va s'effondrer et donc
aujourd'hui je pense qu'il en est
parfaitement conscient
les systèmes je pense que le le le pr le
premier ministre japonais en est aussi
conscient ça fait vingt ans que ça dure
ça fait 20 ans qu'il est mais qui fait
tourner la planche à billets ça fait 20
ans qu'il n'a pas eu de croissance et on
est riche à en
arme suprême pour pour faire repartir
l'économie monsieur berneau nous balade
depuis cinq ans nous disons je vais
faire beau ce baisser le chômage grâce à
mes quantitative easing très bien que
c'est faux on voit très bien qu'il n'a
pas relancé la machine on voit très bien
qu'aujourd'hui on est face à les etats
unis c'est un c'est un drogué
avec une perte dans le bras qui se prend
4 milliards par jour de chou c'est tout
monsieur verrier est ce que vous pensez
clé le comportement prédateur des états
unis sur leur politique extérieure un
cycle en comporte prédateur sur
l'émission de dette sera tenable sans
petites perturbations sur les autres
économies
il ya déjà des perturbations soient
cette économie est pas pour rien que le
brésil est en train de prendre des
mesures aussi pour limiter les entrées
de capitaux américains parce qu'une
partie de skis et crée évidemment fui
les états unis etats unis ont la monnaie
de réserve mondiale dont qui ont des
facilités à faire des choses qu'on
n'aura pas l'aura pas de la même façon
qu'ils exportent aussi en partie leur
leur inflation
mais ce qui est intéressant là dedans
c'est qu'on est face à de nombreuses
bulles
[Musique]
monétaire bulle des actifs l'huile
obligataire qui ne repose que sur la
confiance 5pour moment et de la
confiance toujours le système tient ce
trade étonnante quand on parle de bras
les gibbons 10 comme juste n'importe
quoi s'est uni soit toujours triple a
pour plusieurs agences de notation je me
sers un paquet des agences de notation
ont contourné dans une situation aussi
désespérée
la confiance est là et effectivement
comme ça dure on a des politiques en
fait ce qu'ils disent bat pas très grave
bon on a imprimé 2 milliards par jour au
marché voit on pas des masses mais
essayons trois essais en quatre
maintenant le japon 10 essais en huit
le problème c'est que la confiance et
les binaires y en a il y en a pas c'est
pas chez confiant ce lundi puis mardi un
petit peu de mercredi puis beaucoup je
dis non vraiment on est en train comme
dans ces jeux pour enfants où ça les
espèces de petites pyramides vous
enlever un truc chacun votre tour et
puis ça tiens ça tient à ce qu'elle joue
dans les ch'tis tout s'écroule et c'est
ça qui risque de se passer à force de
faire n'importe quoi sur les monnaies à
force de faire n'importe quoi sur les
marchés mais un jour ça marchera plus
effectivement il va y avoir un politique
qui va dire mais c'est fou ça a marché
pendant 25 ans j'en ai fait juste un
tout petit peu plus et ça n'a plus
marché du tout car le jour on va se dire
qu' il faudrait mieux qu'eux
notre salaire en le convertissant francs
suisses 1 parce qu'on va voir des gens
qui vont s'agiter du côté de la banque
centrale ça va poser de lourds problèmes
il ya le yen a chuté certes les japonais
ont perdu 20% de leur pouvoir d'achat
international en quelques en quelques
semaines suite aux déclarations
effectivement on n'a rien vu mais
monsieur lambert en cas de perte de
confiance généralisée à votre avis que
peut-il se passer
l'affaissement des économies c'est moi
tout ce que j'ai constaté dans le passé
l'occasion des postes d'observation je
me suis trouvée c'est que les économies
fonctionne bien à des taux de croissance
relativement élevée satisfaisant lorsqu
elle conjugue un accroissement de
l'investissement
le bal du pays et de la consommation
lorsque seule la consommation fonctionne
ou le seul investissement fonctionne on
a des périodes de croissance médiocres
en plus de contenu ray en revanche quand
les deux moteurs ses deux moteurs
fonctionne de pair et bien l'économie
est sur un rythme de croissance
relativement soutenue
bien entendu si on arrive à rester rey
aujourd'hui dans la plupart des grands
pays développés et singulièrement dans
l'autre une confiance qui permettent le
retour à l'investissement
ce que ce que les entreprises ne
pratique absolument pas pour l'instant
pour différentes raisons parce
qu'effectivement n'ont pas confiance
n'ont pas confiance et deux parce
qu'elles n'ont pas forcément les moyens
leur taux d'autofinancement est
dramatiquement faibles s'est affaissé
depuis quelques années si on arrive à
relancer cette confiance je pense qu'on
peut renouer avec une certaine forme de
confiance et cette forme de confiance
peut se traduire aussi par le fait que
les tirelires en passer par les gens en
france en particulier mais c'est vrai un
peu partout en europe je pense
se casseront alors que ces tirelires
pour l'instant pour objectif de se
prémunir contre le chômage d'un enfant
de chômage n'a pas pu parler on cassera
la tirelire et rocco samora à ce que la
confiance est revenue qui permettra le
retour à l'investissement est bien ce
jour là on aura enfin enfin une
croissance réelle stables relativement
vigoureuse mais elle ne sera plus un à
l'image de celles qu'on a connues dans
le passé ça sera du 2-2 et demi pourcent
j'imagine donc au maximum vous parlez de
confiance
de la confiance qu'est ce que vous
pensez d'affaires qu'elle jacques
senez phénomène mort on reste immense a
introduit une chute de confiance
instantanée instantanée et moi je les
relis davantage cette affaire qui a eu
sa commande de d'éthique de morale de
nos sociétés actuellement et qui en
résulte du fait que tous les jours tous
les mois vous voyez un énorme scandale
ce qu'ils acceptaient toute petite chose
par rapport à une hormone il ya quelques
années par rapport à goldman sachs par
rapport à morgan stanley par rapport à
la deutsch bank par rapport au problème
du libor
tous les jours vous avez quelque part
'l'annonce d'un annahda manquements
profond fondamental à l'éthique et
finalement tout ça ne touche plus
personne sert qu'on est là on regarde
tout ça avec des yeux complètement
affadi sans s'interroger sur ce que tout
ça signifie même si olivier delamarche
monsieur lambert a parlé de du libor
qu'est ce qu'on peut me dire du liban
pour
autre chose ça fait un scandale en effet
qu'on a quel était ce scandale pas mal
pas mal étouffé
finalement puisqu'on en parle de moins
en moins quelques quelques banques ont
payé une petite amende au passage pour
se débarrasser de la chose
mais c'est eux
c'est comme tout c'est comme tous ces
scandales c'est à dire que on en parle
pendant quelques quelques jours quelques
semaines
sur les sur les média cd sont des choses
en tout cas pour ce qui concerne le
libor que qui touchent pas directement
les les
les gens parce que c'est compliqué de
comprendre comment ils ont manipulé les
choses et que ça donc les gens oublient
vite et en fait ces décès des scandales
en effet qui porte sur des sur des
dizaines et des centaines de milliards
et qui sont réglés en sous main avec une
petite amende monsieur monsieur bernier
moi moi ce qui m'étonne dans tout ça
c'est qu'on s'en étonne
ça fait trente ans on est rentré dans
une idéologie très clair
d'ultra libéralisme ou de libertarisme
qui consiste à dire en gros il ya une
main invisible du marché qui surtout je
veux dire mais attendez n'ayez comme
seul le comportement personnel d'être
égoïste et on nous dit pas la peine
d'avoir des repères éthiques ou d'un
repas vous soyez gaulliste ça va bien se
passer mais cette règle la sienne ne
repose sur aucun critère éthique elle
pousse à quoi elle pousse à la
malhonnêteté forcément en tout cas la
condition est que vous pouvez vous dire
mon but n'est pas d'être honnête mon but
est qu'on ne sache pas que je suis mal
honnête ce qui est très différent donc à
chaque fois vous pensez que vous allez
pouvoir être malhonnête sans vous faire
prendre vous le faite puisque c'est ça
votre critère essai en contre au duc
times et à qui on retrouve du enron et à
chaque fois en dix ans passés bizarre
que ces boîtes quand même on se rend
compte qu'elle se foutent de nous et
pareil pour les banques et quand même
qu'en conséquence logique quand on
regarde dans le détail
on se rend compte que toutes les
personnes qui sont un petit peu
incriminé avec quelques scandales
derrière eux ils ont exactement le même
parcours on retrouve toujours des gens
très hauts placés dans la finance on
retrouve toujours des gens passer par
les institutions de pouvoir je suis en
vert qu'est ce que vous en pensez est ce
que vous pensez qui a réellement
une attraction à des niveaux supérieurs
pour se couvrir des scandales qui nous
ont permis d'atteindre un certain niveau
de responsabilité
ces personnes qui font partie de la peur
classe comme vous dites ont simplement
les l'objet d'un pouvoir qui permettent
des entorses à l'éthique significative
mais il y en a d'autres à des niveaux
subalternes je pense pas que ce soit
limité à à une partie de la population
le problème 50 sans preuve que plus
c'est à dire que c'est devenu d'une
grande banalité alors savent ça entraîne
le passage dans des sectes certain
nombre de gens qui ne croient plus à
rien donc qui se précipitent vers des
sectes ou vers des extrémismes religieux
moi je crois qu'on va pas pouvoir
continuer à survivre de cette façon j'ai
une idée un peu folle pour ma part
survivre c'est un grossiste à recréer un
minimum d'éthique de ce libéralisme qui
est sans foi ni loi
et qu'il faut donner des règles de
conduite alors comment le créer ce code
éthique et bien en faisant se réunir un
certain nombre de gens
représentatifs chacun d'un courant de
pensée de l'espèce humaine se dire les
grandes religions monothéistes le
bouddhisme l'hindouisme le grand croyant
les agnostiques les libres penseurs les
francs maçons en y ajoutant peut-être
quelques fromages quelques prix nobel de
la paix quelques prix nobel
scientifiques il faut faire en sorte de
créer un espèce de con s'il entre des
gens respectés en nombre
limité autant que faire se peut pour que
leurs travaux soit efficace qui fasse
que
chacun des sept milliards d'individus de
la planète se sente représentée par l'un
d'entre eux et il faudrait que par une
espèce de jaillissement spontanée vous
voyez la difficulté de l'opération ce
concile ce conclave et met les tables de
la loi du libéralisme c'est à dire
quatre pages 10 pages d'une grande
portée sur condamnant définitivement les
l'enrichissement sans cause insolente
nature la traite des enfants
le travail des enfants de façon à ce que
les enfants arrivent au travail le jour
où ils ont acquis un minimum d'autonomie
intellectuelle condamne définitivement
les inégalités hommes femmes et c'est
donc ces tables de la loi
on les a tous sans l'esprit d'une
certaine façon elles sont pas codifié et
moi je rêve je fantasme sur un conclave
de gens de cette nature de cette qualité
qui les élaboré alors j'y travaille en
fait avec unesco avec une association
qui s'appelle la fraternité d'abraham
peut être avec sûrement de l'institut de
france et je ne désespère pas de réussir
à organiser une telle réunion dans le
courant
je n'espère pas vous avez branché hélas
pas sur wayne là vous allez vous avez
parlé de franc maçonnerie pourquoi
mettre des francs-maçons autour d'une
table parce que les formations sont une
forme de pensée que qui ne faut pas
négliger moi je suis pas les coups
francs maçons mais il se trouve que
j'étais invité à faire une conférence
devant je ne sais plus et el gran torino
et franck pellerot orient
sur la guerre économique
à la suite de laquelle j'ai assisté un
cocktail de cette obédience et j'ai
trouvé le climat de cette loge
chaleureux sympathique bonjour c'est une
forme de pensée qui ne me choque pas que
je n'en fais pas partie parce que je
n'ai pas voulu me faire des bienfaits d
mais voilà donc je ne voudrais négliger
aucune forme de pensée contemporaine
dont les les personnes représentées à ce
conclave vous parlez de table ronde sur
internet nous sommes conscients d'un
organisme qui s'appelle les bilderberg
ce qu'est ce que vous pouvez nous dire
sur les beagles berck ville de berck
c'est comme la trilatérale comme davos
ce sont des espèces de club
de bon aloi ou retrouver des grands
banquiers internationaux des gros seins
des grands chefs d'entreprises de toute
nature industrielle de service
je pense que les médias sont présents à
ce genre de réunions dans certaines je
pense oui les villes de berne a fait
mille merckx est ce que ça va inscrire
massivement le mil le maire je ne sais
plus j'ai dû y participer ou de deux
fois il ya très longtemps
ainsi qu'est la trilatérale je me sens
pas pour autant coupable de quelques
comment dire d'avoir partager des
secrets honteux c'est une grande
simplicité vous avez là donc des chefs
d'entreprise des grands banquets des
grands financiers des hommes politiques
ils arrivent avec leur credo d'un
libéralisme
il on parle abondamment pendant deux ou
trois jours épuisant repartent en ayant
gravé dans un espèce que dans un espèce
de disques durs les modalités de ce
libéralisme voilà donc ça améliore
légèrement le fonctionnement de ces
libéralisme hélas pas suffisamment pour
éviter les excès dont on vient de parler
donc ne donnons pas une importance
excessive à ce genre de rencontres
d'avancé l'avancé frappant je veux dire
aller dans ce sens rien j'ai participé
une expérience tout à fait à nantes à
davos un jour le président davos le
créateur
m'a appelé et m'a dit bernard curé créer
un groupe de ce qu'on appellera les
académiques lieders à l'occasion
d'approcher la prochaine réunion de
davos il s'agira des présidents des 15
plus grandes universités mondiales
et alors j'étais très flatté de son
parti j'ai lu tant que c'est président
de l'école polytechnique il a fait venir
effectivement quinze présidents de
grandes institutions d'enseignement à
davos gt2 rapporteur général du groupe
et nous a dit bah écoutez préparer moi
un message pour l'humanité alors on
s'est enfermés pendant 48 heures
j'essayais de rédiger en anglais
balbutiant elle est la synthèse de vos
travaux et on a effectivement élaborer
un message de quatre ou cinq pages qui
reprenait les thèmes que je viens
d'évoquer sur le mont travail des
enfants l'égalité hommes-femmes la
suppression des enrichissements selon
etc plus quelques autres
messages sur l'éducation la formation
des hommes en général on a amené tout ça
à monsieur claude fabre directeur de
davos qui a rangé sa dans un tiroir
qu'il a fermé à clide à notre super
factions et qui nous a dit non davout
s'aimait pas de message donc voilà il
n'y a pas de message danser dans ces
structures il ya simplement des espèces
de près consensus qui se transforme en
consensus plus accentuée à l'issue des
réunions sus de la marche je vois
sourire
oui parce que ce oui toutes ces réunions
c'est fait pour
manger des petits faut il en ai jamais
rien sorti comme le g20 pareil
comme les réunions du fmi pareil il en
ai jamais rien sorti on a des
déclarations fracassantes mais mme
lagarde ou
ou autre
avec le rien dedans donc je dirais que
c'est comme d'habitude on est emmené
aujourd'hui c'est
j'ai dit la semaine dernière sur bfm de
toute façon il faut que les moutons se
tiennent tranquilles pour qu'on puisse
les tombes
les il faut il faut donner il faut
donner une petite musique
qui endort aux moutons pour qu'on puisse
les tondre tranquillement donc c'est ce
qui est fait c'est ce qui est fait quand
on donne des chiffres qui sont faux et
archi faux c'est des chiffres du chômage
des chiffres de la croissance des
chiffres de
l'ons le fait en permanence en parlant
des chiffres du chômage les chiffres de
vendredi
sur la téte hic sur les états unis un
consternant c'est qu'on continue à
exactement comme com comme depuis
plusieurs mois et même et même plusieurs
années
ont fait disparaître des gens il ya six
cent trente mille américains qui tout
d'un coup ont disparu c'est à dire qu'on
fait baisser le taux de participation à
la possible à la population active qui
n'a jamais été aussi bas et
si vous remettez ça sur les la moyenne
de taux de participation à la populace à
la population active si vous remettez ça
sur la moyenne aujourd'hui il ya 11 6 %
de chômeurs aux états unis d'accord donc
si vous prenez le chiffre après étendu
qui est ce que ce qu'ils appellent la
composante eu 6 c'est à dire les gens
qui travaillent quelques heures par part
par mois et sert à vous retrouver
avec un taux de chômage qui est proche
des 10 9% enfin numérique 1 sur 5 quand
même hein et après quand vous allez dans
le détail vous apercevez que le chômage
a jamais duré aussi longtemps vous
apercevez qui a jamais eu autant de deux
contrats de 2 à durée déterminée de
contrats d'intérim etc vous apercevez
que on a
depuis 2008 on a créer 4 millions
d'emplois aux états unis sur les plus de
55 ans
et que en revanche la partie moins de 55
ans c'est à dire les jeunes américains
là on a perdu trois millions d'emplois
mais ça choque personne et on continue à
vous dire ah mais les états unis sont
pleines
réindustrialisation et on regarde les
chiffres et là on s'aperçoit qu'on vire
tous les jeux tous les ans dans le la
partie industrie et manufactures on vit
un mois tous les mois on vire des gens
et on vous dit mais l'avons
réindustrialiser non c'est faux et
aujourd'hui on est on a on n'a pas
engagé un seul type c'est à dire le
quantitative easing n'a pas produit
absolument pas de baisse du chômage
c'est faux archi faux et ça fait partie
de ces chiffres alors on vous fait la
même je vous fait le même coup sûr sur
le logement aux etats-unis où les
banques séquestre les
les habitations qu'elles ont qu'elles
ont saisi pour que pour empêcher le
marché de continuer à baisser donc ils
se retrouvent avec des stocks
aujourd'hui de d'invendus dia de la
rétention bancaires sur les actifs et
évidemment et et
et tout est comme ça c'est à dire que on
a on a le chic visiblement on se demande
si quelquefois les bureaux d'analystes
font leur boulot silice quelquefois
aussi cherchent ici
s'amuse un peu à confronter les chiffres
parce que
parce que c'est c'est juste concernant
le chiffre précis les bureaux d'analysé
ne font pas leur travail est ce que les
journalistes derrière
maintenant non plus mais c'est pas leur
boulot c'est le boulot d'abord d'aider
des bureaux d'analystes des stratégistes
et économistes de le faire après le
journaliste il est là pour pour le faire
dire aux stratégies ce mais c'est pas
son boulot d'aller d'aller chercher ça
il pourrait le faire mais il le fait pas
il avait des incohérences partout c'est
à dire qu'on est en train de regarder
aussi les incohérences qui assurent le
sur le le mythe de l'indépendance
énergétique américaine si vous regardez
les la production de gaz de schiste
exter vous apercevez qu'on est en train
de vous vendre une salade qui va être
probablement très indigeste voilà donc
mais simplement il faut se pencher sur
les choses il faut essayer de bosser un
tout petit peu
ça c'est paris c'est fatigant mais vous
avez mal vous parlez de ddn d'énergie
monsieur lambert comment pensez-vous
dans ces conditions financer la
transition énergétique en france en
europe et dans le monde toute cette
pyramide de dettes des gouvernements qui
ont pas aidé leurs citoyens à financer
cette transition le financement des
importations énergétiques s'est toujours
fait par les exportations je sais leur a
été d'ailleurs leur raison d'être au
départ la première balle en sus les
premières balance du commerce extérieur
il ya 40 50 ans étaient des balances
commerciales faire d'une grande
simplicité il y avait d'un côté les
importations énergétiques
et préfinale et puis des exportations
produits destinés à couvrir ses
importations alors c'est ajouter à cette
première balle ans progressivement à
partir de 62 d'ailleurs de 1962 une
deuxième balance des échanges de
produits industriels et un tel enseigne
que le poids des exportations est passé
de quelques pour cent de la richesse
nationale du pnb à 20% dès les années 70
depuis comme le commerce international a
continué à croître et à faire en sorte
qu'une troisième balance s'ajoute aux 2
premières voire même une quatrième on en
est à environ
un poids des échanges internationaux
dans notre richesse de l'ordre de 40%
dire que tout en moyenne on travaille
presque un jour sur deux pour
l'exportation pour pour l'importation
donc tout ceci c'est toujours jusqu'à
présent résolu de cette façon pour nous
français en particulier avec un excédent
de notre commerce extérieur c'est
d'ailleurs par don de faire une
parenthèse c'est cet accroissement
boulimique du commerce international qui
a crû d'environ 7% de plus que la
richesse mondiale en termes réels
terrain at-on énorme 27% ça veut dire
par an ça veut dire le doublement en dix
ans ce qui d'ailleurs à ces produits
terre le doublement de la part des
échanges internationaux dans la richesse
internationale en disant c'est ce qui
m'a conduit à élaborer cette théorie de
la guerre économique parce que c'est par
le biais de ses exportations et de ses
importations qu'on a propagé le virus de
la compétitivité qui a lui-même entraîné
toutes les économies qui ont participé
dans cette croissance importante 5 6%
pendant 20 ans puis de deux ennemis 3%
suite et c'est ce qui a permis cet
enrichissement moyens mais qu'a eue la
cruauté et l'ars de de laisser subsister
des écarts de super u de revenus
considérable le financement de la
transition énergétique la france qu'est
ce que vous en pensez des voeux est-ce
que vous pouvez aussi expliqué à hunter
le signal prix qu'est ce que veut dire
le signal prix pour pour au niveau du
financement
lui même dire et c'est un sujet
on en parle beaucoup le patrimoine en
france est de 13 mille milliards d'euros
pense qu'on a de quoi financer des
transitions énergétiques ont ce que ça
ne démarrera pas tant que en effet au
niveau 2 au niveau des prix vous n'avez
pas un prix du pain du bus un prix du
litre d'essence à 3 ou 4 euros et relais
à ce moment-là vous inquiétez pas que
quand ça va arriver et ça va arriver
beaucoup plus vite qu'on ne le pense
vous allez avoir forcément besoin de
convertir un peu votre votre économie
anwar un contrario j'ai envie de dire
aussi c'est un sujet important c'est
bien d'y réfléchir un peu c'est pas le
sujet urgent je jure jean cerner face à
une pyramide de dettes qui va s'écrouler
on est face à une monnaie européenne qui
est subclaquant tu dont personne ne sait
comment on en sort sans avoir des dégâts
colossaux là dedans mais je pense que
c'est plutôt de là dedans qu'il faudra
mettre un certain nombre d'énergies et
de d2 et de réflexion pour rebondir sur
ce qui a été dit tout à l'heure aussi
j'avais envie de faire deux trois de
trop petites remarques de niveau
différent au niveau de l'éthique et au
niveau du comportement
moi ce qui me frappe c'est que quand on
est aussi dans une époque où il ya eu un
affaiblissement gigantesque à 22 des
valeurs collectives
très amusant il ya quarante ans vous
aviez des combat qui a été mené en gros
entre une pensée on pourrait dire de
droite catholique 1 face à une gauche
communiste diamants très différente en
apparence mais qui de toute façon portée
du collectif en s'aperçoit que les deux
se sont se sont écroulés que ça a été
remplacé par rien si ce n'est pas une
idéologie de l'individualisme agir bien
soyez égoïste penser qu'à vous ça se
passera bien tout comme en 89 on a vu
s'écrouler un monde où on avait mis que
du collectif est plus du tout des
libertés individuelles bah là on est en
train de voir s'écrouler probablement
mon bon ami que de la liberté
individuelle et plus du tout le
collectif être mendient ce qui vous
manque pour faire lien et pour faire un
pro faire société moi j'ai pas la
réponse mais bon ce manque là et quand
même sans doute structurants dans ce qui
se passe aujourd'hui deuxième réflexion
sur le
sol toujours plus un pas la croissance
allait rapidement toujours plus toujours
plus de biens toujours plus de
croissance il y aussi un aspect
financier a vraiment toujours plus
d'argent toujours plus de hautes
rémunérations et quand on voit les les
évolutions des rémunérations des
dirigeants des grandes entreprises c'est
quand même assez fabuleux pendant 80 ans
j'ai eu des ratios de 1 20 à 40 entre le
pdg et le salaire affaires de
l'entreprise donc apte à 400 mais il ya
des boîtes c'est à dire et à 8000 passer
du assez proprement du délire et c'est
quelque chose qui à mon sens atteint
vraiment les fondements mêmes du
capitalisme et de sombres de son
acceptation donc j'espère qu'il y aura
aussi là dessus des évolutions qui
seront sans doute plus brutal que ce que
j'aurais souhaité mais on voit que quand
on veut mettre un taux à 75% sur des
rémunérations qui déjà
sont délirantes pour du salarié bondy
inconstitutionnelles c'est pas possible
pas faudra peut-être arriver à les
limiter un peu plus un peu plus
brutalement au niveau je répète des
salariés des très grosses entreprises 1
un troisième point sur le sol politique
aussi sur laquelle j'avais pas j'avais
pas rebondi
pense qu'il faut qu'on réfléchisse plus
aussi à nos institutions alors dire on a
des institutions qui sont évidemment
celles de la cinquième qui ont été
bâties
1958 donc pendant les trente glorieuses
qui sont des institutions qui marche
très bien quand il faut distribuer 6 %
croissance dans le pays on s'aperçoit
quand à 3% de croissance ça ne sait
faire qu'une chose c'est de la dette
pendant 30 ans et quand on arrive à 0%
de croissance on se rend compte qu
évidemment on peut plus faire de dettes
et que doit on nous dit qu'on est censé
rembourser les dettes des 30 dernières
années on voit qu'on n'y arrive pas et
ce système porte en lui aussi une
sélection
je trouve d un des élus un de niveau
national et de ce qu'ils sont vraiment
sur le devant de la scène donc c'est que
10 ou 15% du total mais il ya 900
députés et sénateurs ben on réfléchit en
en connaissant et les autres on l'est on
les connaît pas si j'en à seissan là
malheureusement souvent en sa personne
pour arriver à ces niveaux là vous êtes
obligés d'être de mentir d'être
malhonnête de enfin voilà enfin vous
sélectionné quelques par les individus
les plus pervers parce que pour arriver
à être élu être en tête devant tous les
autres
pas franchement c'est quand même
extrêmement difficile ça demande une
implication personnelle qui est
délirante et je pense que personne
autour de cette table n'est prêt
vraiment à faire face est très difficile
aujourd'hui d'être au service un peu de
son pays bon dans le système de
sélection vous sélectionnez ces
individus j'appelle les plus pervers on
s'aperçoit de temps en temps quand on
met un coup de projecteur sur certains
banks par la majorité mais quand même un
certain nombre par bruce avait des
individus qui à force d'avoir été
malhonnête avec leurs électeurs
finissent par être à bama l'honnête tout
court donc il faut qu'on ait une
réflexion sur comment on sanctionne et
dans ce système là on s'aperçoit qu'on
ne sanctionne plus yahoo qu'est ce que
va avoir monsieur cahuzac sans doute pas
grand chose on attend de la semaine
dernière qu'ils pensaient comme à
revenir à l'assemblée on se dit tiens
c'est quand même une sanction
intéressante vous avez ça partout les
subprimes aux états unis enfin vous avez
eu des milliers ou des dizaines de
milliers de fausses déclarations envers
des chômeurs qui gagne mille dollars par
mois qui déclare l'an dernier dix mille
personne n'a été poursuivi le pdg qui a
coulé dexia quand même bien nommé pierre
richard continue à percevoir sa retraite
tranquillement chapeau est-ce qu'il est
venu à quelqu un médium et il faudrait
peut-être déjà quand même expliqué qu'il
a probablement menti au moment de son
embauche puisque j'imagine qu'il a
déclaré qu'il était compétent mais la
suite a montré pas c'était pas tout à
fait tout à fait la réalité mais voilà
enfin je suis un peu dur mais il ya plus
de sanctions dans ce système là les
dérives sont son sont importantes et
charmant non sanctionnée évidemment
qu'on finance fonctionne pas bah le
suivant il continue en a pas parlé les
stress tests des banques au milieu de ce
stress test depuis quatre ans qui nous a
expliqué que les banques irlandaises ça
marchait vraiment bien que les banques
chypriotes ça marche et drôlement bien
que dexia marché drôlement bien où on
voit ça peut nous avons fait n'importe
quoi au niveau des stress tests des
banques et que boya pression que l'ours
pas bien grave attendu le jour vous
allez prendre une dizaine de consultants
vous leur dites fait - as tristesse
d'une banque si la banque hoult aura
cinq ans de prison je vous garantis que
le stress tests il va être de grande
qualité simplement il rit de vous
montrer que la banque était déjà en
faillite c'est souvent monsieur je
change mon d'une fois sur le chemin de
la marche mf global
les sanctions
le mécanisme qu'est ce qui s'est passé
avec mev global jon corzine at il pris
des conseils reggae qu'est ce qu'un soin
conseilleriez qu'elle aille je vous
laisse leverage
mf global c'est le problème du leverage
c'est à dire qu'à un moment
vous aviez jeux de mémoire 35 ou 36 de
d'effet de levier
à un moment vous faites vous faites une
erreur et vous sautez cesser enfin là il
faut quand même que les gens se rendent
compte et olivier a raison il n'y a pas
eu de sanctions en 2008 les banques ont
on a senti le boulet du canon passé pas
très très loin de nos têtes à tous à
cause des banques vous avez vu un
changement non aucun donc on a continué
joyeusement a utilisé quasiment les
mêmes effets de levier on à voir
quelquefois pour certaines banques à
augmenter leurs bilans la société
générale
aucune leçon ne sert donc vous comptiez
et
dans le même esprit puisque toute façon
vous n'avez pas de sanction donc vous
pouvez couler une banque met 25 mille
personnes au chômage
coûté quelques milliards à la
collectivité vous n'êtes pas sanctionné
donc pourquoi voulez-vous que sa faute
préconisations à court terme c'est
durcir les sanctions à durcir les
sanctions
faire ce qu'a demandé
olivier ce que nous on réclame depuis
depuis très longtemps c'est à dire c'est
par l activité bancaire de l'activité
marchés revenir un glass steagal
tout à fait tout à fait hermétique et
définitif voilà toutes choses qui ne
sont ne sont pas fait parce que
finalement s'aperçoit alors on nous dit
oui l'angleterre a pris la décision il
l'angleterre a pris la décision pour
ça ne sera pas fait c'est donc et
aujourd'hui on en parle en france
monsieur hollande je crois en avait
parlé visiblement il a oublié un ces
problèmes de l'alzheimer je pense
précoce donc voilà il
parce que parce que vous avez
aujourd'hui ddv lobby bancaire qui sont
très puissants les banques se sont
regroupés et
aujourd'hui quand vous leur demandez
quelque chose il faut le disent parce
qu'on les a sauvés et c'était en 2008
qu'il fallait réellement faire les
choses là maintenant ils sont ici ils
ont l'impression d'être tous sens en
grande forme et quand quand vous leur
demandez quelque chose ils vous disent
non ils vous disent non sur deux en dix
ans yves si vous nous embêter on prête
plus à l'économie ça fait déjà un bon
moment qu'ils prêtent plus à l'économie
mais c'est pas grave ils le font croire
et donc évidemment le ministre concerné
entre dans son bureau en dix ans surtout
ne vous dérangez pas
la transition est autour y rentre
justement là l'éthique non vous parlais
tout à l'heure le parcours politique et
les
pressions potentielles du monde
financier
votre parcours monsieur lambert vous a
permis de résumer
votre pensée votre
idée sur ce les différents leviers et
préconisations possible d'être dans
votre ouvrage ici présents est-ce que
vous pouvez nous donner quelques pistes
selon vous à suivre pour d'abord je dois
faire notre armure pour revenir sur ce
qui vient d'être dit bon sur la
séparation des activités de banque
d'affaires et le nombre de dépôts bien
sûr
il faut t'y venait il faut refaire un
glacis glace il ya là qu'en france c'est
clair ce qu'on a fait une plaisanterie
de garçons de bain jeudi à finaliser ses
activités elles le sont déjà de toute
façon donc c'est vraiment selon la
société générale ça ne représente que 0
5 000 militaires
a dit son président devant je prends une
commission est tout à fait fondée à me
saouler à monsieur vous dire voilà sept
tirs la plaisance est vraiment là
plaisante et dias honda bon peu importe
sur l'individualisme ça c'est un sujet
quand même beaucoup plus importantes
toutes les études sociologiques actuelle
montre qu'effectivement il ya cette
immense retour à l'individualisme qui se
traduit d'ailleurs dans son plan
religieux par le développement des
sectes par le développement des églises
évangéliques il s'en crée une tous les
quinze jours en france les églises
évangéliques c'était tout à fait
étonnant par le fait que chacun se fait
sa religion à sa carte en prenant un
petit peu de de catholicisme judaïsme
l'islam de chacun se
prépare sa propension
idéologique
tout ceci est vrai est-ce que c'est
extraordinairement dangereux est ce que
c'est qu'on donne un je ne le crois pas
on s'est vite d'abord le retour à des
système coercitif commun mise en place
par des gens qui deviennent rapidement
des tyrans quand il est au contraire
trop de convergence comme ça a été le
cas en union soviétique et dans l'ip
lait dans l'allemagne nazie simplement
encore une fois il faut cadrer tout ça
lui donnait un sentiment de morale
beaumont idée un peu folle encore une
fois de créer ses tables de la loi
sur le plan
sont sur le point sur le plan éthique
sur les écarts de salaire une anecdote
quand j'étais moi-même président d'une
entreprise
mon salaire a présenté 15 fois celui du
lait la rumeur obtiendra la rémunération
la plus faible de l'entreprise quelques
années plus tard ça c'était dans les
années 70 80 quelques années plus tard
dans les années 90 c'était car c'est
monté à 50 60 70 alors j'ai fait un
grand article dans le fil rouge et droit
une page d'ailleurs qu'il n'est plus
jamais arriver
dans lequel je condamnais ceux se ses
écarts de 50 70 80 qui me paraissaient
quand même déjà trop élevé et fillon
avait titré et lambert condamne l'écart
des salaires de 1 à 70 est effectivement
en état entre 500 de 1 à 500 voire un
ami aujourd'hui et sans que personne n'y
trouve à redire d'une certaine façon
c'était appelé les chefs d'entreprise
qui en bénéficient comment dire sont sur
une autre planète ne vivent pas sur
terre ne se rendent pas compte de
l'effet produit par des rémunérations de
cette date yeux qui engendre se dire des
sentiments très forts des crispations
très forte au niveau populaire et c'est
bien naturel et au niveau de
l'entreprise elle-même exhalons pas mal
même l'état drac avait fait des travaux
très intéressant là dessus on y voit et
s'entend mais cette amnistie est d'une
certaine façon par ou anesthésié plus
tôt par les stock options des
distributions d'actions gratuites que le
sage qui comme au kiki seuls qui font
qui solidarise des responsables des
patrons un certain nombre de cadres
bref à sa fin c'est peu certes il ya
quelques poussières donné mais enfin
comme toute façon le cadre se met à
avoir un patron qui gagnent 100 200 x
ski ce qu'ils gagnent hui vous aurez
quand même aussi cette
ce sentiment là même qui était décrit
très bien par pléthore du caire en
expliquant une phrase assez rigolote 110
dans le problème avec avec ça c'est pas
tant que les patrons ont perdu
l'estiment de leurs prix de base bon à
la rigueur ça ça n'arrive jamais et
lampes led basse pense toujours que le
patron est un escroc mais ils sont en
train de perdre l estime des des cadres
supérieurs voire des dirigeants de
premier niveau qui pensent que leur
patron est un et 1 était un escroc à
quelque part qu'ils veulent c'est cette
rémunération la lente reprise sachant
lui-même à des récompenses de plus en
plus de plus en plus limitées donc en
tout cas c'est très destructeur aussi
sur le sentiment d'entreprise en tout
cas en terme de perte de respect
qui mériterait quelques analyses
sociologiques intéressante si vous vous
demandez mais comment dire mes
préconisations et réalisation de ces de
cette heureuse si on parlait de la
situation française par exemple que
faut-il faire en france bien il vous
prendrez s'attendre de mesures
drastiques difficile qui de toute
évidence vous le logement ou un système
de retraite à la carte ou l'allongement
de
la durée du travail de toute évidence
malheureusement on ne comprend pas il
faut prendre servait une pause dans
l'évolution des rémunérations de toute
nature parce que le le malheureux
crédits d'impôts suite au rapport
gallois ne comblent qu'à peu près un
tiers de l'écart de compétitivité qui
existe entre notre économie l'économie
allemand donc les deux autres tiers
doivent bien être trouver quelque part
par proment par une pause qu'il faut
faire pour permettre aux entreprises de
regonfler leur capacité
d'autofinancement notamment d'un bref ya
un certain nombre de mesures à prendre
qui sont toutes relativement populaire
qui pendant deux ans
reese massivement tous ensemble doivent
permettre de nous permettre
effectivement de retrouver une forme de
confiance et un coin de ciel bleu à
l'horizon simplement je ne crois pas que
politiquement aucun gouvernement
actuellement de gauche ou de droite soit
capable de les mettre en oeuvre qui
restent seront fatalement impopulaires
qu'il avait quelles qu'elles soient de
gauche ou cas soit droite je vais dire
est donc
à ce jeu je plaide pour
un espèce de gouvernement d'union
national de salut public représentant
regroupant des gens de bonne volonté de
part et d'autre sert des hommes
politiques modérés je connais aussi bien
à gauche qu'à droite
quelques technocrates
ils sont pas tous comme on dit et
sans intérêt loin de là et qu'un
gouvernement pendant deux ans mettre en
oeuvre toutes ces mesures et puis au
bout de deux ans bien coupe sifflé la
récréation est terminée si j'ose dire la
bataille politique reprend au moins on
aura remis le le pays à niveau et encore
une fois ça sera rude ce sera un effort
difficile
le mot de la fin d'autres non mais une
fois qu'on est face à des situations
peut-être assez assez paradoxal on
parlait de l'individualisme tout à
l'heure mais on se dit si je mets trop
d'individualisme et ça finit par
brouiller le système économique un ça va
créer un désordre massif et on sait très
bien que la population face à un
désordre à choisir à l'ordre plutôt qu'à
liberté donc ça risque de ramer des
régimes autoritaires également l'euro
dont on a parlé on dit souvent d'être un
peu rapidement l'europe c'est la paix ok
peut-être mais six mois parce que
l'europe c'est la paix que l'euro se
sera pas la guerre je le problème c'est
que ça pousse un des leurs autour de
nationalisme un retour d'égoïsme
extrêmement important en europe quand on
voit ce qui se passe aujourd'hui comment
sont perçus les allemands dans toute
l'europe du sud prend des bonnes ou
mauvaises raisons enfin par rapport à ce
qu'ils avaient il ya cinq ans 10 mai
donc ça a pas l'air d'aller vraiment
vers la concorde universelle en europe
ce ce truc là alors en conclusion que
faire ou quelques quelques idées
moi je pense vraiment qu'il faut arriver
à prendre conscience que
l'augmentation phénoménale du secteur
financier depuis depuis une quinzaine
d'années quelque chose de malsain
j'aime pas le terme financier parce que
c'est pas un secteur financier qui s'est
développé sa secteur spéculatif c'est un
financier est indispensable on en a
besoin c'est plein de gens brillants et
de toute façon d'ailleurs même dans tout
ce système là c'est plein de gens
brillants partout mais dont la plupart
sont en train de travailler la ruine de
l'économie réelle de l'économie
industrielle de l'économie note on a
besoin d'économie industrielle
de prendre conscience que ce secteur-là
n'est pas sain et qu'il faut le
dégonfler rapidement wac on en est très
loin on continue à considérer que c'est
presque une solution peut avoir des
banques qui ont quand même type et leurs
bilans par 4 5 ans 15 ans est sain et
qu'il faut absolument préserver tous ces
produits dérivés qui ne sont que des
produits purement de spéculation des
espèces de produits casino qui met en
danger l'ensemble du système économique
malheureusement la loi bancaire dont on
assez peu parlé rapidement entre nous
tout à l'heure mais on peut parler dans
les médias montrent que malheureusement
la conclusion est que le système n'est
pas réformable je suis toute la roue a
dû être mais par f1 sans un épisode
douloureux évidemment mais qu'on est
condamné à retaper liesberg une deuxième
fois et peut-être un coût du système et
c'est ça qui est assez qui est assez
flippant parce que la loi bancaire quand
on voit les positions à gauche à droite
au centre sera d'être réglée vite fait
bien fait on aurait dû arriver de
nouveau à la séparation des activités
bancaires qui je le rappelle était la
loi en france entre 45 et en pratique
1995 donc tout ce qu'on demande c'est
revenir au paysage bancaire dès 1995 où
ça marchait pas trop mal on s'aperçoit
que le fait que c'est pas possible il
faut toucher à rien surtout nous ne
limitons pas les des activités ni
rémunération des traders ok très bien
vous comme ya pas de pression
populaire un forte sur ce point la bombe
en est condamné en effet comme l'a dit
olivier delamarche il ya quinze jours à
être tous chypriote bien c'est ça qui
est un qui est devant nous bon c'est
dommage parce que avec un peu
d'intelligence collective à un peu de
bonne volonté on aurait sans doute pu
prendre à des décisions beaucoup plus
beaucoup plus efficiente et moi ce qui
ce qui m'inquiète c'est que des fois je
me dis mais on aurait pris au hasard à
100 personnes on aurait fait une mini
assemblée pour présenter les problèmes
il arriverait à prendre des décisions
parce que les gens individuellement et
sont pas stupides sont pas complètement
irresponsable et quand le système
politique aujourd'hui n'y arrive plus
sans doute aussi par court termisme sans
doute aussi par manque de sanctions sans
doute aussi parce que quand on entre en
politique à 35 ans et contient 70 on
sera toujours là en bas forcément ça
oblige à agir d'une certaine façon qui
n'est pas du tout celle qui est qui qui
serait celle qu'on qu'on emploie récit
on n'était là que pour cinq ans le court
termisme il faut effectivement dire un
mot je veux dire des effets absolument
désastreux on a complètement oublié le
temps long qui devrait régir les
l'économie ça se voit au travers
d'innombrables phénomène les comptes
trimestriels veut dire on aura des
comptes mensuels un jour ou un décompte
quotidien je diront d'ailleurs elle est
surtout apprécié prêteront ils sont
capables de faire des comptes quotidien
avoir décompte horaire je ne sais pas à
face caricature mais donc c'est si on
est dans un système qui devient
complètement fou
et qui n'engendre pas d'ailleurs le
désir d'investir de faire de la
recherche développement maire de
l'innovation une des mères de
l'innovation mais cela on la principale
donc tout ceci fait qu'effectivement ce
court termisme que auquel sacrifient les
entreprises françaises actuellement les
grandes entreprises lanto de recherche
développement diminue par rapport à leur
chiffre d'affaires pourrait en permettre
la lah des résultats financiers
trimestriels
peu plus séduisant que ceux prévus donc
ils font ce qu'il faut sortir et
je crois que c'est au gouvernement par
des mesures elle même basée sur un temps
long de donner l'exemple et d'entraîner
de nouveaux les entreprises mais à ce
stade il faudrait il changer la culture
de tous les analystes financiers des
agences de notation bon ça ne se fera
pas en un jour d'autant que le phénomène
est partie des états unis et que c'est
eux qui tiennent un petit peu dans ce
domaine les leviers du pouvoir
comment dire intellectuelle et l'os le
problème c'est que c'est une sacrée
paire nation de notre fonctionnement
sociétal forcément quand on a dérégulé
dans les années 80 si vous dérégulé pour
venir quelque part une loi de la jungle
et donc quelque part vous êtes obligés
d'être court termiste parce que si vous
êtes long termiste face à des
entreprises des concurrents qui sont
court termiste vous allez perdre donc
évidemment vous avez un développement de
cette vision à court terme donc de
vouloir faire des profits à très court
terme dans le secteur financier vous
avez des moyens d'en faire un très court
terme qui couleront la boîte à cinq ans
ou à 10 ans mais c'est plus votre
problème puisque vous êtes vous mêmes
dirigeants qu elle est restée trois
quatre années en poste et gavés de stock
options qui sont donc une espèce de de
paris faramineux sur l'évolution de la
bourse et donc 2 ce que les analystes
vont penser de votre action donc ce
système là est malsain et c'est triste
parce que il ya plein de mesures simples
qu'on pourrait prendre sans difficultés
majeures avec un petit peu de courage et
un petit peu de compréhension de ce qui
se passe pourquoi si je fais un profit
financier en 15 minutes ou en quinze ans
je vais tac c'est pareil c'est quand
même fou pourquoi si j'arrive dans une
dans une entreprise aujourd'hui je peux
voter l'assemblée générale demain
pourquoi ma voix demain aura le même
voit pas le même poids qu'un actionnaire
qui sera là depuis 15 ans on pourrait
changer ça pourquoi est-ce qu'on compte
les actions ont continué à la bourse
pourquoi tous les millionièmes de
seconde la valeur de l'action de
l'entreprise change mais faut être
malade vous pourriez très bien avoir une
seule valeur déjà par jour au moins déjà
ça enlèverait toute la spéculation on va
dire que 20 autres à des blagues
quotidienne qui ne sert strictement à
rien qui peut justifier que la valeur
d'une entreprise varie tout les
millisecondes maintenant enfin c'est du
délire et ces trucs là on pourrait le
faire 95% des gens sont d'accord si
c'est pas 100% on ne le sait pas mais
c'est dramatique c'est déjà les mesures
simples qui aident on le fait parce que
les mesures compliqué on les fait pas
non plus les gens ne fait rien père
resto ainsi et regardons liesberg
s'approchait tranquillement de nous ce
sera le mot de la fin peut-être olivier
delamarche un dernier mot oui on est
passé de gouverner c'est prévoir
gouverner c'est pas voir sa prochaine
élection
[Musique]